- Hello, everyone.
It's very exciting to start out
this science lecture series.
Sandro Galea was an emergency
physician and epidemiologist.
He's the Robert
A. Knox professor
and Dean of the
Boston University
School of Public Health.
He is the former
chair of epidemiology
of the Columbia
University Mailman School
of Public Health.
Prior to his academic
career in public health,
Dr. Galea practiced
emergency medicine in Canada
and served in Somalia with
Doctors Without Borders.
He was named one
of Time magazine's
epidemiology innovators in
2006, and Thomas Reuters
listed him as one of the
world's most influential
scientific minds for the
social sciences in 2015.
Dr. Galea is a past president
of the Society for Epidemiologic
Research and elected member of
the American Epidemiological
Society.
He was elected to the National
Academy of Medicine in 2012
and shared two of IOM's most
recent reports on mental health
in the military.
Dr. Galea serves frequently
on advisory groups
of national and
international organizations.
He formerly served as Chair of
the New York City Department
of Health and Mental Hygiene's
community services board
and as a member of
its health board.
We are thrilled to have Dean
Galea here, and please join me
in welcoming him.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good evening.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, everybody, for
inviting me to come and present
here.
It's really a
pleasure to be here.
So I'm delighted to open
this series, although I'm not
entirely sure that I am going
to do justice to epidemics.
Because my title is
about epidemiology
counts, but I want to talk less
about the academic application
of epidemiology, which those
of you who are not so inclined
may be relieved, and more
about the core meaning
of epidemiology.
And by the core meaning
of epidemiology,
I mean that, since epidemiology
became a discipline
roughly 150 years ago,
the core definition
has been that this epidemiology
is about understanding
the causes of health so that
we may do something about them.
So understanding
the causes of health
so that we may do
something about them.
And I actually think
that that meaning--
so in my title, I said
epidemiology counts.
I think that meaning counts.
I think that it is important to
understand the causes of health
so that we may do
something about it.
And I'm going to
make an argument
that how we think
about those causes
has clear consequences for
whether we succeed in promoting
healthy populations or not.
So that's the arc of my talk.
And I'm going to start off by
trying to lay out a challenge,
and say, this is what
we'd like to get to.
Point out some problems and
then offer some solutions.
And then, of course, I
would be delighted to have
some questions.
So let me plunge right in.
So let me start by arguing
that we want a healthier world.
And when we say you
want a healthier world,
it seems to me reasonable
that, if this is the world,
we are interested not simply
in a few people with disease,
schematically.
We're actually interested in
understanding the whole world
and understanding a universe
of people who may have disease.
Right?
That our interests are
not particular to just
a small group.
We're interested in a
healthier world for all.
It seems to me like
it's a tough argument
to say that we want
something else.
And ideally, we want to
understand the health for all,
and assuming that the
people in the dark blue
are disease people,
so that we actually
make them better, right?
So ultimately,
what we want to do
is we want to
understand the world,
understand about the disease,
and make some people better.
That's ultimately
our aspiration.
Now, I start with
this-- and this
is a very, very simple concept.
And you're going to say,
OK, OK, I know that.
That's OK.
But this has
implications for how
we think about the cause of
health and the cause of disease
and what we do about it,
as I'm going to get to.
Now, let me start
with good news.
I'm going to start with--
there's abundant good news.
One of the challenges of
being an epidemiologist
or a public health person is
I always come to audiences
and I talk about people dying
and being sick; it's all bad.
So I want to start
with good news.
All great stuff.
This is the best slide I know
that says good news all around,
which is this.
So this is life expectancy
from the 1500s to the present,
and what I want you to
see is the longest records
of life expectancy
are in the UK,
and life expectancy really
grumbled along around 40
all the way till about 150 years
ago-- really in the mid 40s
till about 100 years ago.
So life expectancy grumbled
along, like, 40 to 45.
And I would ask
everybody in this room,
how would your life decisions
have been different had you
expected to die at 45?
And I mean, we all know
people do die at 45,
but let's be honest.
We expect to live
much longer than that.
So, not so long ago--
100 years ago-- we could
expect to live till 45.
Now look what's happened
in the past 100 years.
It's been this extraordinary
zooming upward.
And these are just
selected countries.
The United States is over--
I can't remember which
one of these it is.
And it's one of these.
But we can see all
countries zooming up
in the past 100 years.
So that is extraordinary.
Like, this is great good news.
We haven't gained, in
the past hundred years,
about a 40% increase in life
expectancy after having not
budged life expectancy
for hundreds of years.
That is great good news.
And you can see this good
news manifest in all sorts
of other ways that
we measure health.
So I'll give you
another example.
This is global child mortality
between 1800 to the present,
and the red is the
share of children
who died before age
five, and the blue
are the ones who
live past age five.
So look at 1800.
That's not that long ago.
I understand in our
short lifespans,
200 years seems
like a long time,
but it's actually not that
long ago in human lifespan.
Nearly half of all children
used to die before age five,
and look at today.
We're down to
under five percent.
Right?
So this is all good news.
So we've done some things right.
So I want to start
with the good news.
Now, if it's all
a good news story,
you probably don't need
to invite me to say, well,
there are things that
we should do better.
So let me talk a little bit
now about how we fall short.
And I'm going to start
with a domestic lens,
and then I'll-- for briefly,
I'll expand to a global lens.
But let me start domestically.
So this is a
sophisticated audience,
so everybody is going to
know the first slide I'm
going to show you.
So the first slide I'm going
to show you, domestically,
is this.
But this is non-communicable
disease mortality.
So is death from, essentially,
non-infectious diseases.
The line between the two
blurs, but that's fine.
And all I want
you to see here is
that this is the US
comparing ourselves
to any number of other
high income countries.
You know, we're worse
even than Greece,
and goodness knows they
can't get anything right,
but we still kill more
people than they do.
You know, Italy,
Japan, Spain etc.
I always like putting
in Greece in there,
because whenever I compare--
like if I compare to
Sweden, everybody says, ach!
But the Scandinavians, they're
just good at everything.
But you know, hard to
argue the same for Greeks.
So we have worse
life expectancy--
I speak above people from
where I come from, so it's OK.
But everybody knows this.
You all know that life
expectancy, or the measure
on any number of health
outcomes in this country
is worse than our
peer countries.
Everybody walked into
this room knowing this.
Now, what I suspect
you do not know
is that it wasn't
always like this.
And in fact, it wasn't
like this not so long ago.
So let me show
you another graph.
So the way to read this is,
this is 1980 to the present.
These are the OECD countries--
high income countries.
There are 17 of them.
The gray dots are
all these countries,
the red dot is the US.
So in 1980, we were
in the top half.
Everybody see the
life expectancy?
And over the course
of the past 35 years,
we have steadily
drifted to the bottom.
Now, there's an
upward slope here,
so our life expectancy
has been going up,
but at a much slower
rate than everybody else.
So we now have the
worst life expectancy
of any of our high income peers.
The bad news is that
we have wrought this
upon ourselves in 35 years.
The good news is, well, if
we've done it in 35 years,
we should be able to reverse it
over the next 35 years, right?
That's the good news.
This is clearly not intractable.
Because I feel like
the public discussion--
the informed public
discussion about US health--
often stops at the slide
and says, oh, it's terrible.
It's terrible.
We're worse than everybody else.
Yes, we are.
But we weren't always that bad.
We actually-- not so long
ago, we were not that bad.
Now how bad are we now?
I just want to deepen
the misery for a second.
So I'm going to show you
two slides about mortality
in the US compared to median
mortality in high income
countries.
And I'm just going
to divide them
by age, just to make the point.
So let me start
with young people.
And by young, here, I take the
liberal definition of under 75.
So young people under
75 75 is the new 55.
We all know that.
So here are people under 75.
So here's the way to read this--
the blue is mortality
in the US, the red
is median mortality in all the
other high income countries.
So what you see;
under one, one to 14.
So first of all, you see this
U-shaped mortality curve.
That's very standard.
We have more mortality at the
youngest stages, more mortality
as you older, right?
Nothing surprising there.
But then look at this.
We kill more newborns than
anybody else, you know,
and that's not--
the safest age to be
is always one to 14.
That's like when you
live, and then you
start killing people again.
But look at this--
the blue bar is always
higher than the red bar.
So we are consistent that we
kill more people at all age
groups than all the
other high income
countries, which at least
would give us for consistency.
So that's slide A, but now let
me show you the second slide.
If I may take the
liberty to say over 75
is the older age group--
not old, just older.
So now let's flip to over 75.
So these are over 75.
And now you see, again,
US and other countries.
So this is 75 to 79.
Roughly even.
Over 80 we're less,
85 we're less, 95-99,
100 plus were less.
So we actually are doing great
in mortality over age 75.
So this is an amazing
country to live in
as long as you
live until age 75,
because then you live forever.
Because then, nobody dies.
If you go to, like, 150, our
mortality goes really way down.
So when you compare
how we're doing
to these other high income
countries and just rank us.
So you rank us, one through 17.
There are 17 OECD countries.
One through 17.
What's our rank?
So here's a graph of that.
The way to [INAUDIBLE] these
ranks, [INAUDIBLE] 17, so 17
is bad.
There are two lines
here, men and women.
They behave the same.
Pretend they're one line.
So we are 17th.
You see it?
17th, roughly, at all
age groups all the way
to age 75, all of a sudden,
poof, we jump to number one.
So we are great.
Now, you say, OK,
OK, OK, but you're
complaining that things are
not as good as they could be.
But we just don't--
you know, you
start off by saying
we care about health
of populations,
but maybe we don't, really.
What we really care
about is shiny iPhones
and having nuclear weapons
that we can drop on Korea.
I mean, that's
what we care about.
We don't really
care about health.
So we're not spending that
much money on it, so it's OK.
This is OK.
This is what we get.
Well, that's not true, because
this is national spending.
All these colored lines are all
the other rational high income
countries, and the
purple line is the US.
So are we spend nearly
40% of our GDP on health,
and our rate of
increase is steeper
than anybody else, and our
change in the rate of increase,
which means second
derivative, is also
steeper than anybody else.
So we spend a lot
of money on health.
And perhaps the best
graph to capture
that-- if you want to have a bar
fight with someone about this,
this is the best graph,
because it maps life expectancy
and spending.
So you see all these countries?
You know, more spending,
more life expectancy.
And you see us, where you
have more spending and life
expectancy sort of trundles
down the non-trodden path.
So there are clearly
problems, right?
And it seemed to me, when I was
given the challenge of opening
up this magnificent
lecture series you're
having, that if I
was going to talk
about the causes of health,
like, I felt like you couldn't
start this lecture series
without understanding
these basic facts.
Now this is the US.
I just want to,
just for a second,
make a quick global comment,
because ultimately this
has to be a global lens.
So let me just go back to a
slide like the one I showed you
earlier.
This is maternal mortality.
This is death of
mothers in childbirth.
And what you see here,
you see the US, again,
is higher than all these other
countries I showed you before,
right?
So nothing surprising there.
But all I want to
do here is, I'm
going to add one more country.
I'm going to add to
this graph Ethiopia.
So maternal mortality,
I add Ethiopia.
That's Ethiopia.
That's the same graph.
Let me go back.
You see these countries here?
Just look at the axis.
0 to 16.
Now the axis is in the 0 to 400
scale, because that's the US
and that's Ethiopia.
So I just did want to, for
a second, take us out a lens
to say that, while I was
talking about the domestic lens,
there is absolutely no
reason why we don't take
a global lens, and from point
of view of health equity,
there is absolutely no
reason why this happens.
This is just as
unacceptable as is that.
OK?
So I just want to label
that, that these issues are--
one can take a national lens
as well as a global lens.
Now, let me get to the
crux of my argument.
So where do we go wrong?
And I want to make a
three part argument,
and then I will counter it with
a sort of three part solution
just for the sake of symmetry.
And why is this the case?
Now, there's plenty
of blame to go around,
and I approach this very much
from the perspective of someone
who has spent my professional
adult life, really,
within the Academy.
So I tend to tend
to try to figure out
where I've gone wrong, where we
collectively have gone wrong,
rather than trying
to point fingers
at broader, other forces.
But with that in
mind, I think there
are three places we
have gone wrong, which
I think gets at this notion I
was trying to make that, if we
understand the causes of health,
that has real consequences
and allows us to act properly.
So three ways we've gone wrong.
Number one.
Number one, we lose sight
of what causes health.
Now, you all say, well, I
know what causes health.
Well, you know, heart disease
and stroke and cancer,
et cetera.
So, that's not quite right.
And I want to illustrate what
causes health with a story.
So This is a blues man.
His name was Blind
Willie Johnson.
So this is the only known
photograph of Willie Johnson.
Any of you who like the blues
will know Blind Willie Johnson.
He was born at the turn of
the 19th century in Texas.
And he was born in
Texas, he was poor.
The story is that
when he was three,
his mother threw lye in his eyes
in an act of domestic violence,
and he became blind.
He lived fairly poor.
He learned how to
play the guitar,
he made money playing
the blues, and he busked.
Essentially, that's
the way he made money.
He was married, he lived in a
house, the house burned down,
he had no money so
he continued living
in the burned down house.
And when he was 44,
he developed malaria.
So blind Willie Johnson,
who was blind, poor,
and black in Texas, and
this is now in the 40s--
1940s-- his wife took
him to the hospital,
where he was turned away.
Unclear whether he was turned
away because he was blind,
because he was black, because
he was poor; and went home
and died.
So the question is, what
killed Blind Willie Johnson?
Well, obviously the
malaria killed him, right?
But it wasn't just
malaria that killed him.
Right?
It was his malaria,
it was racism,
it was domestic
violence, it was poverty.
All of that killed Blind Willie
if malaria didn't get him,
something else was going
to get him any day, right?
Now, why am I telling you
this obvious, obvious story?
I'm telling this obvious
story because unless we
ground a conversation in the
foundational causes of health--
unless we understand
that, if we fix malaria,
and we don't deal with the
racism, with the poverty,
with the domestic
violence, we are not
going to fix health for all.
We actually go down a
totally different path.
So I'm starting with
an obvious story.
Now, I would argue that
while this may be obvious,
this is in no way where our
national conversation is at.
And that's bad news.
But here's good news, perhaps--
that this kind of battle
about what causes health,
we have been having in the
world for hundreds of years.
Here's a classic example.
These two generously
mustachioed gentlemen
are two of the founding
fathers of public health.
The gentleman on the left is
Edwin Chadwick, the gentleman
on the right, William Farr.
And William Farr is
credited with being
the father of statistics.
He started life table
counting in the UK.
Edwin Chadwick is the
architect of the British Health
Act of 1848, which was one of
the sentinel health acts that
created health in cities.
But they had a big
argument, and the argument
was as follows-- that William
Farr, who was counting deaths,
said that the babies
of poor mothers
were dying more than
babies of rich mothers.
So he said, poverty is
killing these babies.
Edwin Chadwick was a
politician, and he said--
and there's a quote
which I'm not going
to get exactly right, but--
babies do not die of
poverty in civilized London.
He says, it's not poverty.
So what was it?
Well, it was
nutritional deficiency,
said Chadwick, that was killing
the babies, not poverty.
And the argument
went back and forth,
because Chadwick
was a politician;
Chadwick won, and nutritional
deficiency was recorded.
But the reason I'm
showing this is
because this gets at
the heart of how we
think about what causes health.
Now, how about today?
What is the
implication for today?
In Epidemiology 101,
Public Health 101,
any health 101 class
anywhere in the country,
you will have a discussion
of a table like this, which
says the causes of death
in the United States
are heart disease,
stroke, et cetera;
or tobacco, poor diet,
alcohol consumption, bugs,
toxic agents, etc.
And these are the
[INAUDIBLE] those people.
But is that what causes health?
Or is this what causes health?
Low education, low social
support, racial segregation,
income inequality, poverty.
Look at the number
of deaths from this.
Low education, 190,000.
Acute heart attacks,
roughly the same.
Low social support,
stroke, roughly the same.
Racial segregation,
lung cancer, the same.
Obviously, all of these
are causes of health.
I'm in no way saying
it's this, not that.
But what I'm saying
is that, unless we
keep our eye on the multiplicity
of causes of health,
we will not invest in
these other causes.
To go back to the
Willy Johnson example,
we'll invest only in malaria and
forget about everything else.
Now you say to me, oh,
we're better than that.
We're better than that.
We understand this.
There, there.
Why don't you sit down.
We get this.
We know that these
things matter for health.
Of course we invest in them
when it comes to health.
But do we?
Now, we're in Massachusetts.
We have the privilege of
being probably the most
progressive state
in the country.
Do we understand this
in Massachusetts?
Does our money follow
where our ideas are?
Let's look at where health
spending is in Massachusetts.
Massachusetts health spending.
These are causes of health.
It's a real schematic.
You know, access to
care, most people
think it's about five to 10%.
Genetics, socioeconomic
physical environments,
healthy behaviors,
interaction about everything.
Here's our spending.
90% of our spending is
on medical services,
but less than 10% is
on healthy behaviors.
Most estimates are that we
spend 3% to 5% on things
that aim at prevention.
How has this changed?
You're like, OK, well, maybe
this was bad over time,
but it's changing.
We're getting better.
Let's look at change over time.
Past 15 years, Massachusetts
spending 2001-2014.
We have increased our
spending in medical care 81%.
Kept the same or decreased,
primary and secondary
education, law and public
safety, mental health,
public health, higher education,
early child education,
and environmental education.
So you tell me that we actually
understand the Blind Willie
story.
Because surely if we understood
it, we would not be doing this,
right?
And this, of course,
directly maps on
to the slides I
showed you earlier
that talk about the
fact that the US spends
far more than anybody else
and has far worse health
indicators.
Because of course we are
spending more than everybody
else, but we're
spending it on just one
aspect of what causes health.
In some respects, if
the audience actually
understands that point,
my work here is done.
Because the core point is that
if one thinks about the causes
of health-- remember,
that's how I started--
and one understands that
there's a full range of causes.
If we're spending on
only one of those causes,
we are inevitably going
to be underperforming.
I want to show you
a metaphor, and then
move onto the second thing
I think we're doing wrong.
So this is the best
soccer team in the world.
This is the US Women's
National Soccer Team.
And I know that soccer is not
the most popular sport here,
although in Massachusetts,
it's probably better.
But for those who don't
know how the game is played,
there are 11 people on one
side, 11 people in the other,
and they get the ball to the
other side and try to score.
They can only use their feet.
That's why it's called football,
it's the real football.
Except for the goalie.
The goalie is this
woman right here.
They wear a different uniform.
Her name is Hope Solo,
she's a terrific goalie.
Yeah, anyway, there's
just-- good goalie.
Leaving that aside.
The goalie can catch
the ball with her hands.
Now for those who don't
know soccer, football,
the misconception is
that the way to win
is to have a great goalie
so that any time the ball's
coming at you, you
can save it, right?
But anybody who
knows football knows
that when you look
at a good goalie,
she is spending all her time
yelling at her teammates.
And what she's
telling her teammates
is, get the ball away from me!
Because every goalie knows,
doesn't matter how good she is,
you are going to score on her
if the ball comes close enough.
So the metaphor is this--
the goalie is medicine, right?
We want a good doctor.
We want good medicine.
I want to be very clear on this.
As Sean said in my introduction,
I started my life in medicine.
When I'm sick I want a
great I want a great doctor,
I want a great goalie.
But I would rather the ball
never comes near the net.
And how do you do that?
Well, that's was for the
other 10 players are about.
And those other 10 players
are those other dimensions
that I mentioned and
blind Willie's story.
They are the racism,
they are the violence,
they are the homelessness,
they are the poverty.
They are what we're
under-investing in
in Massachusetts.
Early childhood education,
public parks, public safety.
That's what those
other 10 players are.
And that is what ultimately is
the core combination of causes
of health, and that's
what we misunderstand.
So, issue one.
We misunderstand
the cause of health.
Issue two.
This leads us to focus
on the urgent rather than
the important.
So let me just talk a little
bit about a couple of things
that are potentially important.
And actually, this
echoes one of the
lectures you're going to
be having in the series
later, obesity.
Let's talk about
obesity for a second.
You have a lecture, I think,
called the obesity epidemic.
I just want to show
you one slide that--
three slides, actually.
I've captured the
obesity epidemic.
I'm sure you'll see
this in that lecture.
This is obesity
in the US in 1990,
and the darker the color
is, the more the obesity.
All I want you to see
here is, in 1990, you
had several states that
had about 10 to 15%
of their residents
who were obese.
There was 1990.
Jump to 2000.
Now you have a lot
of states-- actually,
only one state is even in
that range, 10% to 15%.
15 to 19% in all these
states, and these states
are all 20% to 25%.
And you jump to 2010 where 20
to 25%, 25-19, more than 30%.
That's over 20-- what did I say?
1990 to 2010.
20 years, right?
20 years.
Just to be clear,
20 years is a blink
of an eye in human
time span right?
Like, for all of us,
our life's been short.
Twenty years is a long time.
But it's actually not.
Life-- 20 years is [INAUDIBLE].
So this is a problem, right?
This is a problem.
Over 20 years.
Now, let me ask this question.
What has not changed about
humans in the past 20 years?
One thing that has not changed?
What do you think
has not changed?
I know you can think of all
many things that have changed.
I mean, something's
changed, right?
I mean, something's changed.
I mean, we're all fatter,
so something's changed.
If there's a cause,
something's changed.
Tell me something
that has not changed.
Genetics, right.
So the obvious.
You got there right away!
So therefore, given
this epidemic, of course
it makes sense that
we're not going
to invest more and
more in genetics,
because clearly genetics
can't explain this, right?
So, you know, we launched a
Precision Medicine Initiative,
also called
personalized medicine,
and this is our funding in
genetics over the past 10
years.
Now you say, OK, OK, OK.
Well that's-- you're
making a strawman argument,
because of course we are aware
of this epidemic and realize
it's bad, so our funding
and everything else has also
increased, right?
Because you know, for
example, that things like this
have happened.
Look at this food, 20 years,
the number of calories, today;
a bagel has gone from
140 to 250 calories.
Cheeseburger, my
favorite, has almost
doubled the number of calories.
Pasta-- don't even go pasta.
it's 500s.
So those are things
that have changed.
So surely, understanding
this, what we have done
is, we have spent more
on these things, right?
More on research in these areas?
And the answer is, not really.
So we have focused on
areas that, I think,
are urgent and not important.
I think it's discovery science.
I want to be very clear--
discovery science, the
Precision Medicine Initiative,
has tremendous potential.
And I want to be very careful
in my comments, that in no way
am I saying we should
not be doing that.
I'm simply saying that we are
investing in the wrong areas
if one comes from a
place of understanding
the core causes of
health states, which
is why this is ultimately framed
around the core cause of health
states.
So is the second problem.
And the third problem is this.
This has resulted in a loss
of confidence in our science.
And this is a very simple
cartoon which I quite like,
which is the newscaster saying,
according to a report released
today coffee can cause
depression in twins,
but equally well,
he could have said
day care causes a feeling of
well-being in men 25 to 40.
This matters!
This matters because I often
ask our faculty and students
this question.
Whose job it is but ours
to communicate the causes
of the health of populations?
It is ultimately the fundamental
job of those in the Academy.
So if we are, A,
misunderstanding the causes; B,
focusing on urgent
but not important;
C, that inevitably is leading
to loss of confidence in us,
which leads to
poor communication
of these causes, which
means that society will not
be acting appropriately.
So those are the three problems.
Now, I promised I would
actually say, OK, what should we
be doing instead?
Let me start my
three part argument.
Number one, we should be
focusing on what matters most.
And when I was reviewing
my slides, which I
created a couple of weeks ago--
and I was reviewing them
yesterday and [INAUDIBLE]
today, I realized
that the example
I chose in what matters
most as an example
is even more poignant
today than when
I created my slides, because
it's one about firearms.
I had created the slides before
the Las Vegas horror happened.
So we all realize that
there is a firearm injury
problem in this country.
And I'm using choosing
my words carefully.
It's a nonpartisan
comment, it's simply
an epidemiologic comment, OK?
And just to show one
simple example, I mean,
this is our rate of gun
deaths in children and teens.
I'm choosing children and teens,
assuming that by and large they
are not complicit in
their own gun death
and this is the US versus
all other countries.
So when gun deaths happen, there
is a great collective gnashing
of teeth and disagreement on
anything except for one thing,
and one thing alone-- and that
one thing that we generally
agree on is this-- is that
actually, what we should do
is make sure that
guns don't make it
into the hands of people
with mental illness.
Right?
There is broad bipartisan
agreement on that,
and everybody says yes,
that is the problem.
Let's make sure that no
crazy people get guns.
So we'll deal with
our gun problem.
So you might say, OK, well,
does that really matter?
I mean, when you look at
the psychiatric evidence,
people with
psychiatric disorders--
more psychiatric
disorders-- are, indeed,
more likely to be
violent than people
without psychiatric disorders.
There is also, by
the way, people
with psychiatric
disorders are much more
likely to become victims of
violence than those without,
but just to label it, this
is epidemiologically correct.
So as a result, you
get an avalanche of us
saying, OK, let's make sure
people with mental illness
do not get access to guns.
So national instant check
system is, essentially,
checking to make sure
that people are not
eligible for guns, and this
has increased dramatically,
a lot of that because
of mental health check.
So the question is this--
is that likely to matter much?
Well, you know, we have a handy
little experiment here, the US.
But we compare
ourselves to Canada.
I don't know if any of
you have been to Canada,
but for Americans who
have been to Canada,
Canada is just a
lot like the US.
It's only people
like hockey more.
So you say, OK,
what's the prevalence
of psychiatric disorders?
What's mental illness
like in Canada?
So this is the US,
this is Canada.
Bipolar disorder and major
depression and anxiety
disorder roughly the same.
It's a little bit
higher in the US,
but that's not
unreasonable, seeing
as you can't go to a concert
without getting killed.
So broadly, we're the same.
And this is our
firearm homicide rate.
Right?
So what causes the difference?
So what's causing
the difference?
Well, here is the proportion
of households owning firearms.
That's the US versus Canada.
So-- and this is--
I'm reducing a complex
argument, making it very simple.
But if you want a
complex argument,
there are papers that
make the complex argument.
It's very, very clear
that what matters
most in the context of firearm
and the firearm epidemic
in the US is firearm
availability.
Now, we can have a
charged political argument
about what to do about
that, but let us not
allow ourselves to get
distracted by issues
that actually do not matter.
Because what matters most
is firearm availability.
Period.
Solution one, focus
on what matters most.
Solution two, embrace approaches
to deal with complexity.
Now, this is very unpopular.
This is the most unpopular part
of my talk, I realize that.
Because you came here--
astonishingly, even though
epidemiology was in the title--
and epidemiology gives
this impression like,
going to find a cause.
We're going to find one cause.
And I'm here to tell you--
I hope you're seeing that
was the theme of my talk--
there is no "a cause."
There are multiple causes.
There are architectures
of causes.
It's all really complicated,
and not just complicated,
it's actually complex.
And that's why I
show you one example.
So let us for a second
as I presume, if I may,
that, since you all decided to
spend an hour plus of your time
on a lovely Monday afternoon
at the Radcliffes Institute,
you're all pretty smart.
OK?
Actually, when I put it
that way, it sounds--
but anyway, you you
know what I mean.
So I'm going to ask
you one question, OK?
A very simple
question, which is,
how much of your
cognitive ability--
that's a polite word
for brains, smarts--
is determined by your genes.
So, put another way, everybody
here is sophisticated.
You all understand complex
causes, et cetera et cetera,
right?
I settled that.
So here's my question.
What percent of your IQ--
I'm just reducing it-- do you
think is due to your genes?
Now, I would like you all
to be honest with yourselves
and write it down or come up
with an answer, because then
I'm going to back to it, OK?
You need to be honest
about what your answer is,
so I'm going to
give you a second.
What percent of your IQ
is due to your genes?
I don't know, it's--
I'm not taking
questions now, sorry.
Now it's your time to
come up with an answer.
I'll come back afterwards.
Everybody has an answer?
Yes So let me just
show you a schematic.
Here's my schematic.
I'm going to answer
this question.
These are people, again,
as I showed before.
And I'm going to
assume that two things
matter for your IQ, your genes
and your environment, right?
I'm reducing things, but
it seems plausible, right?
That your IQ is your genes
and your environment, OK?
So I'm going to
illustrate the smart gene
as the characters turn black
and the smartogenic environment
as the characters
being in green.
OK?
So smart gene is black,
smart environment is green,
and I'm going to assume
that, to be smart,
you need smart gene
and smart environment.
Now, there are
exceptions to this.
We all know people
who like, you know,
grew up in horrible environments
and they are still smart,
you don't understand
how that happened.
So I'm going to throw in a
few random, like, super smart
people, just like that.
These reds.
So CA plus is
cognitive ability plus,
which means they're smart,
and these people are smart.
But everybody else, apart from
these random smart people,
needs to have the gene and
the environment to be smart.
OK?
That's it.
So then you do a simulation.
So let's do a couple
of simulations.
Scenario one-- here's scenario
one, where the environment
is nearly universally good.
See this?
All green.
These are the red smart people.
These are random smarts,
but then the black--
this is the same as the
genes I showed before.
I'm showing them as dots
here just so you can see it
across the green, OK?
So this is where
the smart genes are.
But the smart gene,
smart environment,
that also becomes red, right?
So what do you see
in this scenario?
Well, what you see is--
I just want to point out
for a second-- everybody who
had the smart gene
became smart, right?
Because everybody who was
black is also in green,
and they became red.
So everybody who had
the gene became smart.
So when you do the math--
I'm not going to bore with
the epidemiologic math--
the relative risk of brains
given the gene is about four,
and the fraction of brains
attributed to genes is 100%.
Why is that?
Just intuitively, because
everybody who had the gene
became smart.
Now you're beginning to smell a
rat, I can see it in your eyes.
Because now I'm going to show
you a different scenario.
Here's the same black
gene pattern, right?
See, the same--
this turning black,
here's the random smart people.
Only these two now
actually overlap
with the smartogenic
environment.
So those two become red.
Now I have a situation
where there's
a lot of people with the smart
gene, and they're not smart.
So when you do the math,
relative risk of 1.7,
the proportion is about 40%.
So the answer to the question,
what percent of your IQ
is due to your genes--
the only correct answer to that
is, it depends on what else
also causes smarts.
Now, I want an
honest show of hands.
How many people- hold
yourself accountable--
said to yourselves
that was the answer.
How many of you said
that was the answer?
Yeah.
It's usually-- in an
audience like this,
it's usually 10% to 20%.
I would like to point out that
I didn't trick you, right?
I didn't-- I did say--
I told you exactly
what I want you to say
and you were entirely within
your domain to say it depends.
But most of us-- by the
way, I do this all the time,
and every single time I
give myself a present,
because it's so easy
to think that way.
The only point I'm making is
that you simply cannot say how
much of your brains is due
to your genes unless you know
other things.
I didn't change the
genes here at all.
All I changed was
the environment.
By the way, is this
all theoretical?
Is this all epidemiologic
flim flammery?
Or No, it's not.
There's actually abundant
data to show this.
This is actually plotting IQ
variance on SES due to genes.
So actually, the richer
people are, the more likely
it is that, the math
shows, that genes matter.
Because of course
it's the same thing,
that you have actually
a positive environment.
Let me go back to the other
topic, actually, before.
This is obesity.
This is a fat David.
What does complexity mean?
Do genes matter for obesity?
Of course genes
matter for obesity.
But do food environments
matter for obesity?
Of course they do.
There's a map of New
York City that looks
at poor food environments.
These are zip codes in New
York City where there is
only unhealthy food available--
South Bronx, northern
Manhattan, central Brooklyn.
By the way, they happen
to be the areas that
also have most obesity.
There's been a lot written about
the food environments lately.
But how about
things like schools?
Where are the bad
schools, by the way?
schools in New York City?
Well, they're in the South
Bronx, northern Manhattan,
central Brooklyn.
Same area.
So, questions.
What's the greatest return
investment to lower obesity,
better food or better schools?
And these are the kind
of complex questions
that I actually
think that we should
be tackling if we
want to understand
the cost of health and disease.
And this is a-- sort of one
analysis that's actually--
the answer to that
question is, if you're
going invest in something
you should invest in schools.
That's the second solution.
So the first solution is
focus on what matters,
second solution is accept
the fact that complexity
is inevitable and
somehow deal with it,
and third solution,
which is-- now I'm
really veering from--
remember in the beginning,
I said this is not an
academic epidemiology talk.
This is not about what happens
in academic epidemiology
departments and
it's not a critique
of academic epidemiology
departments.
it is simply taking
epidemiology at face value
as being about understanding
what causes health.
And ultimately, what causes
health is inextricably
tied with our values.
It's inextricably
tied with our values,
and there is this conflation of
our values with the mathematics
of the causes of health,
and the two are inseparable.
Because ultimately,
if we are not
allowing ourselves to go back to
the Blind Willy story, and say,
we want to deal with
the homelessness,
want to deal with the poverty,
want to deal with the racism,
because without them we're
not going to improve health.
If we say we actually
don't care about that--
all we care about
is fixing malaria--
and if Blind Willie happens to
be black, poor, and homeless,
that's his problem.
If that's what we're
willing to say,
then it changes the
entire conversation.
And that this is a schema which,
actually, I published recently,
which talks about the
challenge that we have
in thinking about our values.
And all I want to
just show here is,
there's sort of a spectrum of,
we don't have enough evidence
and we know what to
do; and over here is,
we actually think this is an
acceptable way to operate;
and this, we don't
know what's acceptable.
So just give an example, polio
eradication is an example.
We broadly know what
to do eradicate polio,
and we all accept that's
a good thing to do.
Zika is a good example.
I heard you say somebody is
coming to talk about Zika.
We don't really have
all the evidence,
although we all agree that we
should do something about Zika.
Now we're getting into
messier territory.
Injection drug use.
We know that syringe exchange
reduces the harms of injection
drug use, and yet, we are
squeamish about expanding
syringe exchange, resulting in
worsening of many infections
diseases epidemics,
like the HIV epidemic.
And then, I put it here,
where we don't actually
know enough about
what we should do,
and we actually don't
know what we value or not.
And of course, the
reason we don't
know enough of what we'll
do is because of the fact
that funding in the area
has been hampered because
of very particular interests.
OK, so, now I'm going to
sort of start winding down.
So, I outlined three problems,
[INAUDIBLE] solution.
You say, OK, but how will
this then change our approach?
So supposing you're right,
which is a big supposition,
how would this approach
change what we do?
Well, we know a lot of
things that, actually, we
can do to improve health.
We know a lot of
causes of health.
I go back to definition
of epidemiology,
understanding the
causes of health
so we may do something about it.
We actually do know
things we can do.
Just to give you
a couple examples.
We have evidence that shows
that if we expand the transit
development in a city of a
million residents by about 40%,
we end up saving about
$200 million in health.
And by the way, I have
citations for all of these,
and I specifically
took these examples
from examples the CDC
has on their website,
just so that you don't
think I'm actually
digging into some journal
[? Academia Obscura. ?]
This is actually-- this
is all on the CDC website.
OK?
Number two.
We do know that
financial support
to create better housing
doubles the proportion of people
with excellent health.
We do know that multi
component work site
obesity prevention programs,
result in about a five percent
weight loss in workers resulting
in $90 average per person
saving a year.
We do know that early
childhood education has
a five-to-one benefit
to cost ratio,
and we do know that every time
we increase the Earned Income
Tax Credit by 10%, we
drop infant mortality
by 23 per 100,000.
These are data that we have.
So why don't we do this?
I mean, my argument
is very simple.
I go back to the
beginning, which is,
we have not been clear about
what the causes of health are,
we have not focused
on what's important--
we're focused only
on the urgent,
rather than what's important--
we have lost public confidence.
But if we focused
on what matters,
if we actually understood
that the causes of health
are complex, and we make sure
that our values were aligned
with what we know,
we would do this.
There's no reason why
we would not do this.
Now, just to be honest, one of
the reasons we don't do it--
and let's just be
honest about this--
is that somewhere in
the back of our minds,
there is this notion that, yeah,
yeah, yeah, OK, that's good,
but I'm smart enough
and well-off enough
that I don't need any of this,
because I can insulate myself
from this badness.
So just briefly, can you really?
Can you really ?
Unless you can wrap
yourself in bubble wrap,
i don't think you can.
Just give a couple of examples.
Up to 50,000 people have
died from flu since 2010.
This is largely
vaccine preventable,
and in no small part driven
by herd immunity around you.
I'm not even going to get into
children dying of a vaccine
preventable disease
because people around them
are not getting vaccinated.
How about children dying
from car accidents?
10% of kids killed
by motor vehicles
are actually killed by
completely unrelated alcohol
impaired drivers.
This is a slide
which I always enjoy.
Your risk of cavities
increases by 15%
if you don't drink
fluoridated water.
One-third of the
country, by the way,
does not have sufficiently
fluoridated water.
Do you know if your water
is sufficiently fluoridated?
How many of you have
checked that recently?
I will not comment about
the Republic of Cambridge.
And, by the way, we
also know that you
know your risk of becoming
obese is influenced quite a bit
by your friends.
So just a very
simple point that,
if you think you can insulate
yourself from all this,
you really cannot.
So let me conclude.
So, at the end of the
day, you came here
to hear about the
causes of health
and why understanding those
causes has consequences for us,
and I just want to
end with a schema that
shows that it is impossible
to improve health
without improving the fullness
of the causes around us,
including the causes
that are not really
about us, but around
the world around us.
So let me just go back to my
schema of sort of small people
here.
And I'm going to show you an
example with blue and red,
and these are the people
in the population.
And supposing supposing for
a second that we accept--
suppose you accept
everything I said.
And you say, OK,
OK, that's great.
I get everything you
said, so we are just
going to tackle racism.
We are just going
to deal with racism.
OK?
So you say, well, some
people experience more racism
and some people experience less.
Note I'm not saying all or none,
I'm just saying more and less.
So red, they're
experiencing more racism.
And you say, look, that is
associated with disease.
So here there are Xs, right,
where there's disease.
And a bunch of people with
the red have Xs in them.
You see them?
They experience disease, and
some part [INAUDIBLE] racism,
but some of the
people in the blue
also have Xs, because
it's not just all or none;
it's just more racism
and less racism.
So that's the way
the world looks.
Now let me just change it
to a simple curve like this.
So this is a simple bell curve.
And this is racism experience.
So let's say that modally--
this is the number of people.
OK?
So this is a lot of racism,
this is a little bit racism.
Let's say that most people
experience somewhere
in the middle.
Some people experience a lot,
some people experience less.
And you say, I get it.
I get what you're saying.
So I'm really-- I just think all
we should focus on is racism.
So let us actually
deal with the people
who experience a lot of racism.
Let's draw a line and
focus on that group,
and if we really work at it, we
are actually going to fix that,
and nobody else is going
experience so much racism.
Right?
So in some respects,
that could be
the conclusion of what I said.
What's the problem with that?
The problem with that is that
that strategy, going back
to my world I showed you
before, sees only this.
Because it's only
dealing with the people
with more racism, which
are the red people, right?
Some of whom have disease
as a result of racism.
But it's missing
all of those people,
because you just
ignored them altogether.
The alternate strategy
is to say, that's racism.
And ultimately, it
comes as a complex
with all sorts of other things.
Yes, access to care.
Yes, homelessness.
Yes, poverty.
Yes, not having adequate food.
All of these things
come together,
and what we really
should be doing
is shifting the entire curve,
and that everybody experiences
a little bit less racism.
Because if we did that in the
population health strategy,
we actually are looking
at the whole population,
and any of the days,
what we're doing is,
we're reducing racism
experienced by people
from all over the population.
And if you'll remember,
that's where I started.
That's the slide I
started with, where
I said we care about
the whole population,
and we care about
reducing experiences
that can produce poor health
in the whole population.
And that gives us a
healthier population.
So I'm going to end
with my last metaphor,
and this is my pet goldfish.
So, as you heard in
the introduction,
for the past few years,
I've had the privilege
of having a dean job.
And the problem
with a dean job is
it's very busy,
particularly combining that
with one's own scholarship.
So I don't have much time for a
pet, but I do have a goldfish.
And I love my goldfish.
And I want my goldfish
to be healthy.
So I say to my
goldfish, we're going
to genotype you to figure out
that we understand your genome,
so that when you are
sick, we can give you
the perfect
personalized medicine
for your particular
little fishy disease.
I say to my goldfish,
you need to exercise.
So I want you to swim
10 times clockwise,
10 times counterclockwise in
your little bowl every day.
And when I feed you little
flaky food, don't eat too much,
don't get fat.
And when you have a
goldfish companion,
make sure you have
safe goldfish sex.
I say all these
things to my goldfish.
And I'm like, OK, I got it.
I nailed this.
And one day, I walk
into my living room,
my goldfish is dead.
How could she be dead?
I'm so distraught!
And there it is.
Ah!
I forgot to change its water.
Doesn't matter
everything else you
do-- if you don't
change its water,
the goldfish is going to die.
So the point is--
what's the point?
The point is, if we care
about the core definition
of epidemiology, understanding
the causes of health,
the causes of
health are complex.
The causes of
health ultimately do
involve the water, as well
as the fish's behavior,
as well as the fish's genome.
Going to to Blind
Willie Johnson,
we need to care
about the malaria,
about homelessness,
care about racism, we need
to care about violence.
And unfortunately,
unfortunately, I
am here to tell you that
there is no magic bullet.
And the reason why
American health indicators
have been as bad
as they have been
is because we have focused
on only one aspect of this.
That if we are serious
about improving health,
we need to take epidemiology
to its core definition,
understand the full range
of complex causes of health,
and work on all of
them at the same time.
If anybody actually is
still interested in what
I have to say, this is my
latest book that just came out,
which actually has a
lot of these ideas.
And that's it.
I'll stop here.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]